Amelia registers vehicles for the
Department of Transportation sports
utility vehicles also known as SUVs make
up 12% of the vehicles she registers let
V be the number of vehicles Amelia
registers in a day until she first
registers an SUV assume that the type of
each vehicle is independent find the
probability that Amelia registers more
than four more than four vehicles before
she registers an SUV so let's just first
think about what this random variable V
is so it's the number of vehicles Amelia
registers in a day until she registers
an SUV so for example if the first
person who walks in the line or through
the door has an SUV and they're trying
to register it then V would be equal to
one if the first person isn't an SUV but
the second person is then V would be
equal to two so forth and so on so this
right over here is a classic geometric
random variable right over here it's a
geometric random variable we have a very
clear success metric for each trial do
we have an SUV or not each trial is
independent they tell us that they are
independent the probability of success
in each trial is constant we have a 12%
success for each new person who comes
through the line now the reason why this
is not a binomial random variable is
that we do not have a finite number of
trials here we're going to keep
performing trials we're going to keep
serving people in the line until we get
an SUV and so what we have over here
when they say find the probability that
Amelia registers more than four vehicles
before she registers an SUV this is the
probability that V is greater than four
so I encourage you like always pause
this video and see if you can work
through it and we're gonna assume that
she's just not gonna leave her I guess
you heard her desk or whatever the
things are being registered she's not
going to leave the counter until someone
shows up registering an SUV so we
we'll just we will just keep looking at
people I guess we could say over
multiple days forever she'll work for an
infinite number of years just for the
sake of this problem until an SUV
actually shows up so try to figure this
out all right now I'm assuming you've
had a go and some of you might say well
isn't this going to be equal to the
probability that V is equal to 5 plus
the probability that V is equal to 6
plus the probability that V is equal to
7 and it just goes on and on and on
forever
and this is actually true and you say
well how do I calculate this this is I'm
just summing up an infinite number of
things
now the key realization here is that one
way to think about that the probability
that V is greater than four is this is
the same thing as the probability that V
is not V not less than or equal to four
these two things are equivalent so
what's the probability that V is not
less than or equal to four this might be
a slightly easier thing for do you
calculate once again pause the video and
see if you can figure it out well what's
the probability that V is not less than
or equal to four well that's the same
thing as the probability of first for
customers or first for I guess people
first for I'll say customers or I'll say
first for cars the customers cars not
SUVs so this one is feeling pretty
straightforward what's the probability
that for each customer she goes to that
they're not an SUV well that's one minus
12 percent or 88 percent or zero point
eight eight and if we want to know the
probability that the first four cars are
not SUVs well that's zero point eight
eight to the fourth power and so that's
all we have to calculate and so let's
get our calculator out and so I'm gonna
get point whoops
I'm going to get point eight eight and
I'm going to raise it to the fourth
power and I get and I'm just going to
round it to the nearest let's see do
they tell me to round it okay I'll just
round it to the
nearest I guess well hundredth well I'll
just write it is 0.599 seven this is
equal to or approximately equal to zero
point five nine nine seven if you wanted
to write this as a percentage would be
approximately fifty nine point nine
seven percent so a little bit better
than half that a 50% shot a little less
than a two-third shot that she is going
to have to see more than four customers
until she sees an SUV